head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
let me pull up this story from the
Washington examiner The View host
Compares Republican women to roaches
voting for raid
quote what's also surprising to me is
the abortion issue I read a poll just
yesterday that white Republicans
Suburban women are now going to vote
Republican she told her co-hosts it's
almost like roaches voting for raid she
was interrupted by Alyssa Farah Griffin
who accused host of insulting voters
the when you have people
who refuse to understand your position
and then listen to Stephen Colbert to
try and understand what your position is
and then he lies to them and says your
position is fake and doesn't exist how
are you supposed to have a reasonable
conversation to move this country
forward when these ideological zealots
outright refuse to even have a
conversation uh start your own show that
was my experience if you don't like what
they're saying about you you got to
start speaking for yourself publicly
right and we've done that and now we
can't expect the woman who is calling
women roaches to want to sit down here
and have a conversation about why she's
wrong I would talk to her but that
convert that sure is crazy can we play
that that short clip of her I mean it's
basically every time you start the
message out you had something you wanted
to say well yeah um I would say if
you're answering that part which party's
getting the message out I would actually
say the Republicans are and I tend to
vote independently
saying that Richard cities is not me
Republican Suburban women are now going
to vote Republican why it's almost like
roaches voting for raid right now
okay she is so arrogant and hateful her
immediate assumption is do these women
want to live in Gilead they're voting
against their own interests we have a
pro-life woman sitting here is voting
pro-life against your in interests
absolutely not I don't know what in her
mind makes her think that abortion is
somehow good for women I mean even if
you are a woman who's been through that
I would say almost every woman who's
been in that situation is horrible it's
not something you want it's not like you
know getting an ice cream cone or or
doing something fun it's it's a very sad
thing and it's it's horrible that leads
to psychological and physical damage yes
many people don't want to talk about
right have regrets over doing that and
so on but aside from that this isn't
something that is something that they
look towards so I think the fact that
the left wants this to be their main
issue for the midterms they basically
want it to be all about January 6th
their democracy being lost in abortion
those are like they're two big things
they want people to vote on and it's
like maybe women actually want intact
families maybe they actually want to be
safe in their neighborhoods they want
men to be men they want all these other
things they don't actually want abortion
why don't we avoid that situation I
think most women would disagree with her
and would not like being called roaches
obviously if she she wants women to vote
leftists in the midterms and they're
watching this this is not a way to
attract them but I can I can certainly
imagine there are many women who want to
be able to get abortions whenever they
want genuinely deep within their souls
they just would love to get an abortion
I mean Lena Dunham said she wished she
had one despite not actually having a
kid she was like no she just wish she
got pregnant that was kind of crazy but
to say that pro-life women who don't
like abortion who want to have babies
and families are voting against their
interests for knowing exactly what they
want is the the epitome of arrogance and
hatred how about she actually let pharah
speak is that her name Alyssa actually
Alyssa speak and say I genuinely don't
understand why a what Republican woman
would vote against her interests can you
explain it to me and then she'd say well
it's not against her interest is it they
believe that these are babies and they
don't want their lives ended so they
wouldn't get an abortion and they don't
think it should be supported hey it's
that simple and perhaps these women
voting think that it's in the best
interest of the child to not kill them I
mean we have to consider all the people
in play what about fathers they often
say how do I have access to my child
even in child custody things they don't
have any say when it comes to abortion
they have no say so I think that there's
so much more to this than just you know
is this in her in her best interest and
I would say it's not in her best
interest it's not in the child's best
interest it's not in anyone's best in
interest in that entire family unit so
what ends up happening with a lot of
policies there's a lot of I think really
important and great things that came out
of the feminist movement I think that's
uh most everybody would agree like women
can vote I know there's a lot of people
who say repeal the 19th but you know
most people are like no that's we're
cool with it although you know there are
a lot of social issues that are
happening now that people argue about I
think what you end up seeing with a lot
of feminist stuff however is detrimental
to women so when you look at hookup
culture who does that benefit men not
women
just just plain as day and and mostly
like wealthier taller you know more
attractive dudes they can fool around do
whatever they want with no
responsibilities used to be that if a
guy want to hook up with a chick and he
did you're getting married because she's
getting pregnant now who cares get an
abortion what was it was it Portnoy he
was talking Dave portno was talking
about this he was debating I think
Andrew Tate on this issue and he was
basically saying like if he gets a girl
pregnant he wants her to get rid of it
you know yeah that's way better for a
guy who doesn't want to be responsible
to for anything and it puts the burden
on women who are now pregnant so the
response so then what ends up happening
is you build a culture where women say
okay then I should be able to just get
rid of it sure I get it but the burden
is still on the woman no matter what it
still benefits the man more if the man
wants to be irresponsible and I think
it's so sad that the left tries to act
like a man giving you 500 to go to an
abortion clinic is empowering that's
like similar to prostitution basically
saying I'm gonna give you money so like
go do this it's like working for a mega
multinational corporation and giving all
of your energy and life towards them is
empowering but supporting your family
isn't yeah I'm
I that the left has sold women basically
that you'll be happy if you spend all
your time in a cubicle you know there
was an article that came out saying the
most unhappy women are women who are
single in their 40s who don't have any
children and work all the time and it's
like big shock yeah because I mean
you're told in your 20s work all the
time work all the time and I totally get
that but at a certain point there has to
be more to life than that and eventually
women say oh I want kids I want a family
then they're like oh my gosh I'm so old
what do I do now and that's why all of
these alternate fertility things are
exploding and it's very unnatural but
needless to say it's like I think things
need to go back to a more a more natural
sense of of the two genders now that's
obviously going to be very upsetting to
the left but conservative women are the
happiest women who who get married have
children have a stable relationship you
know it might be tough but working
things through I think they're much
happier well that's a fact there's
there's numerous studies that show
conservative women married women tend to
have higher levels of happiness and
liberal women tend to have the highest
levels of mental illness so for whatever
reason I don't know but there's a Lexus
Nexus data there's the data scientists
who have pointed this all out I don't
see I I think a lot of the left stuff is
going too far I think there's a lot of
good things in it that we're all like
okay you know we believe in like
classical liberal values Free Speech you
know um innocent until proven guilty and
everyone should have the right to vote
our society changes as the population
grows larger but they get to the point
where it's like the state can take your
children uh marriage is basically voided
out by no fault divorce there's no point
having a marriage like so here's another
thing they lied lied about uh they lied
about when it came to us is we had a
conversation about no fault divorce
we were very critical of it they falsely
quoted Ian as Sheamus I'll never forgive
you for that Sheamus who was it was it
Jezebel yeah yeah and um but the issue
with no fault divorce is that when you
when you say that you can get divorced
for no reason
then you're basically saying marriage no
longer exists because marriage was the
contract by which you could not break
till death do us part then they're like
no you can just right you're done you
know sign up his paper and then split
your money up and you're good okay
what's the point of getting married so
that you can pledge your stuff for a few
years somebody else why do that yeah
it's meaningless yeah a lot of men I
think ask that because they're like oh
I'm basically just agreeing to give
someone money who will take it if they
divorce me and it's like whoa what about
all of the other good things about
marriage which I think it's mostly for
the children it's to create an
environment where they have two parents
in the home of course that's not always
the case great people that's you know
they didn't have that situation but I do
think in general that's what you want to
strive towards and I think the left
wants to destroy that they want to take
kids from their parents send them into
Wilkes schools teach them things saying
hey here's why you should hate your
parents here's why you know your parents
are crazy and all this stuff so no
matter what they want to kind of change
the whole dynamic of society which I do
think goes back to the home
yep yeah without uh family kids are more
likely to drop out of school they're
more likely which well at this point
maybe it's not a bad thing yeah with two
parents working who's going to raise the
children the state you also lower uh
working wages you also increase the tax
base and this is why there's a theory
out there that a lot of this you know
was started because of Edward Bernays
and robber barons and the Rothschilds
that were pushing a lot of these ideas
forward in order to make sure that at
the end of the day they had a system
that benefited them and they were able
to control Society even more yeah at
this point it's If the parents aren't
there is it's not even the state really
if it's functionalism it's the
corporation it's not a television it's
Disney it's it's Microsoft if they're on
the computer it's it's Facebook and
Twitter and who controls Facebook and
Twitter the the federal government I
would like the DHS and they're dictating
what a whole scene in the algorithm
dictating who has a voice and doesn't
have a voice the multinational
corporations are in bed with the
government and with the big Banks here
so at the end of the day it's still the
same interests control trolling and
shaping the minds of the children as two
parents have to work and leave their
children with you know cell phones in
their hands or some Nanny that doesn't
care about them or some State
institution that indoctrinates them to
be essentially a good worker I really
support liberalism in in the sense of
like classical like we're becoming more
uh more free in our society we have more
liberal arts we're able to sing in
public we're able to insult our
government we're able to vote for who we
want and charge uh but it's getting to
the point now where it's becoming
transhumanist and these this this
excessively liberal agenda being like
you can be whatever you want you can do
whatever you want people are cutting
themselves they're they're cutting parts
of themselves off to become what they
want to become and it's like this is
like this is a toxic liberalism there's
a there's an individual who identifies
as a paraplegic woman he's biologically
male and he identifies I think this is
in Norway Norway yes he identifies as a
paraplegic woman so even though his legs
work he gets in a wheelchair and and
then says he's a disabled one that's his
identity you have to respect it at a
certain point we have to start asking
questions of where what are the limits
of identity if someone says they're
disabled but they're not can they claim
disabled benefits like that's that's
that's where we're going thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time